et j'ai fait ma maîtrise en
géomorphologie allez merci de montréal
sur la caractérisation du pergélisol au
nunavik au nunavik on doit construire de
nouvelles maisons pour les inuits et à
49 % des inuit qui vivent dans des
logements surpeuplés
donc il devient urgent de construire de
nouvelles unités d'habitation
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
changements climatiques vont affecter la
stabilité du sol particulièrement le pg
sol par ce qui doit sa stabilité aux
jeunes on a fait des forages dans le
pergélisol
et puis on a rapporté à montréal des
échantillons de sol jolie qu'on a
analysées en laboratoire
donc on à déterminer le type de sol et
le type de glace pour essayer déterminer
comment cela va se comporter si le dégel
on a produit une carte qui indique que à
peu près 50 2 % du territoire à couvrir
les tout qui est à proscrire pour la
construction des infrastructures mais
elle représente aussi les emplois que
les ingénieurs vont pouvoir investir et
davantage ton qui représentent des
sources soit des sources de matériel
d'emprunt pour construire ou bien des
sources potentiellement ensemble pour la
construction en utilisant des
infrastructures spécifiquement adaptés